so hi I'm iris and today i'll talk about
a summer project that I took part in
this past summer in partnership with
Johnson County we were a group of four
fellows myself Christiana Alden and Ben
and one mentor which is Pedro just a sec
let's make sure that I can go next so
Who am I
first of all I'm a PhD candidate at the
Weizmann Institute of Science
before that I pursued a bachelor degree
in computer science majoring in
bioinformatics in the Technion and
master degree in systems biology in the
Weizmann Institute and the section which
I'm going to talk about which was
between my master degree and my PhD was
being a summer fellow in University of
Chicago at this data science for social
good program obviously if you have any
questions during the talk then feel free
to ask them I wanted to say that
beforehand also so what is data science
for social good it's a summer program
and by the University of Chicago it's
held every year and actually
applications opened a week ago so if
you're free this summer and you're even
considering it come talk to me
afterwards I highly recommend it
America's largest mental hospital is a
jail now this statement was said about
Chicago but ask any person who's in
charge or somehow manages a jail system
within America and you'll find that
they'll agree with this statement quite
strongly so we partnered with Johnson
County Kansas you can see here Kansas
and red at the left and within it
Johnson County which is kind of unique
because it borders not only with other
counties but also with state border to
Missouri so we partnered with them
trying to fix that issue of jails being
mental health facilities we came there
and we heard a story about a 19 year old
male who has mmm autism but also some
intellectual disabilities he had over a
hundred police encounters which is by
itself somewhat disturbing
however out of all those hundred plus
police encounters only one of them ended
up with the jail booking and that one is
considered as a horrendous failure but
in general the county wants to eliminate
these cases where people are sent to
jail and instead they should actually
receive mental health assistance and
that's where we come in because we
wanted to change the way the mental
health system works from being reactive
to being proactive and to do that we
yield machine learning tools so our role
was to predict individuals in risk of
entering the jail system in the next 12
months and we put out that list every
month and of those people the 200 with
the highest risk are being reached by
the mental health system okay so what is
currently going on
I mean before we started so they had the
regular reactive intervention someone
has a crisis somebody else calls about
them or they come to the mental health
department and then they get assistance
also if they have a booking then once
they're booked they go through the brief
mental health and the screen that screen
test it's a seven question screen it's
very simple but it simply tests some of
the main mental health issues for
example do you hear voices talking to
you and things like that that can show
that this person needs mental health
assistance if they get a high score then
once they leave the jail system this
will define whether or not they'll get
assistance within the jail system but
also once they leave so if they get a
really high score meaning they
definitely need mental health assistance
they will be out reached once they leave
the jail also if they were a mental
health client beforehand they will also
be out reached once they leave the jail
but what about all the cases that fall
in between those cases that we can
prevent them from being booked and cases
that once they leave the jail system
maybe they need outreach but they
weren't really caught by these two
very distinct measures so to that we
yielded a lot of data specifically
Johnson County Kansas helped hold all of
their data especially jail data from 93
they were the first in the United States
to have all of this data being only
electronic so we got jail data we got
data from police departments we got data
from the Department of Corrections which
is a Kansas facility this means prisons
and not jails we got public health data
we got data about emergency medical
services just a sec and we got mental
health data yeah okay so for the Hebrew
speakers jail is matcel meaning this is
when you get arrested and have not yet
been declared a felon
once you become a felon then you begin
go to prison that's the difference which
is probably why jail holds a lot of
people especially in the u.s. that are
not necessarily felons and they might
even stay there for a very long time so
who do we predict I mean that was our
first question as data scientist who are
we gonna predict and we looked at two
very distinct cases the first one is
people who it is their first booking now
obviously if you intervene at that early
stage before the first booking you're
gonna make a very big difference however
if you predict a recidivism meaning a
second or more time within the jail
system then it's easier to predict you
know a lot about that person however you
might not be as assistive as you could
be and we wanted to cran to quantify
these things before we answer that
question so obviously one is more
proactive than the other but also how
many of the people are currently
targeted and we found that less than 1%
of people before their first booking are
targeted by the current intervention
from the Department of Mental Health and
about 25% from people who have already
been to jail are targeted again by the
Department of Mental Health and then we
asked what percentage of bookings each
one of the population consists so this
is the number of
Kings the x-axis is the enth booking
meaning first second third or more and
the y-axis is the percentage width from
the entire bookings this is for 2017 it
looks about the same for every year so
you can see that about 23% our first
bookings and 77% our second or more
booking which is quite a lot and then we
asked what percent of the people are
gonna be booked in the next year and so
again we did this for 2017 it looks
similar for every other year we looked
at the number of bookings zero like
number of prior bookings this time so we
start from zero and we ask what
percentage of the people are gonna be
booked and you can see that it's very
low obviously for people who have never
been booked and it's much higher the
more bookings you've had before with
some noises within it so in total less
than a half percent of people that we
have data on are gonna be booked in the
next year and about seven percent of
people that we have data on and have
been booked before they're gonna be
booked in the next year and then came
big question about data do we even know
anything about the people who are gonna
be booked in the first time so we looked
at all our data sources and they found
that altogether account to about a half
of the number of people who are going to
be booked for the first time and from
this accounting notice the police
department most of them are actually the
arrests a day before the jail so
obviously that's not really going to
help us so in general we don't have a
lot of data about people before their
first booking and after the first
booking because of the operation
happening during the first booking you
we already have a lot of data like I
mentioned before we have a brief jail
mental health and we have a lot of other
information about them so in total we
come to the understanding that precision
for predicting the first booking will be
vastly lower than predicting recidivism
and so we decided to tackle the problem
of recidivism although now the team that
took over the project from us is
tackling the other problem and so we
looked at examples from the data I mean
it's nice to think about how many people
we could help but we wanted
see concrete example and I will say that
this is somewhat upsetting we looked for
someone who intervened with multiple
systems we didn't expect this so right
now moving so just if you can't hear me
tell me what we see here this is the
arrest
meaning the specific information
associated to the jail and arrests and
these are other sources we have we have
public health data which only starts
from 2004 if I recall correctly we have
the mental health which starts later and
emergency medical services meaning
ambulances which starts even later so
this is a white female she was born in
75 she had her first DUI with a bond of
300 apparently she did something to
break that bond and you can see that
it's the same color meaning it's the
same case number so for some reason her
bond got up to $1,000 and then she spent
time in prison afterwards she had
another case and then she had the theft
and she spent time in jail due to that
theft and she went to family planning
you know family planning doesn't mean
she had a baby it means she had
abortions we were confused about that as
well and I had another DUI she drove
without a license and she went to mental
health care we thought oh that's awesome
she went to get some help not really
this is court demanded because it's once
a week for exactly a year so it's Court
demanded due to the DOI she did nothing
about that come to like a a meetings
okay and so our question is should we
assist her do we think that mental
health department can help her and can
change your outcome now actually when
running the model she probably gets a
pretty high probability of needing
assistance and if we look at her future
outcome we can see that we could have
changed her life quite a lot had several
additional cases after that those
incidents and her tackle with law
enforcement including losing custody of
her children and drug associated arrests
and so we went on to define our baseline
obviously for every model you want a
baseline you want to compare yourself to
something but we're comparing ourselves
to proactive mental health outreach
which doesn't exist so are we going to
compare ourselves to zero because that
kind of sounds like we're saying we're
really great but let's admit that's not
good enough so we looked at existing
baselines first one is LSI our LSI R is
these are different surveys that are
already existing in the county it
calculates risk of recidivism which is
exactly what we're calculating however
it's given to people when they're set
and we'll start before they start their
sentence in the prison which means it's
convicted felons not exactly the people
were looking at it's a much smaller
population so that's not good enough for
us we looked at the brief of jail mental
health screen which I've mentioned
earlier so it's given to all people who
are booked in jail that's our population
however it looks for the need for mental
health assistance not exactly what we're
looking for because we look for people
who are going to enter the jail system
again and then outreach mental health is
amiss a solution but not necessarily
people who need mental health help and
it's given at the moment when they start
their jail term which is again it's a
single time point it doesn't give you an
updated value about the screen unlike
what we want which is changing due to
other data sets that we have information
on that specific individual and then
there's pretrial screen this pretrial
screen looks for are you gonna appear in
court or not this sets the value for
your bond and it looks into all people
who are booked into jail and again it's
pretrial so it only happens once and it
doesn't really get updated so again not
very useful to us
so what we've decided to do is to create
a decision tree using the most known
features from literature which is the
age of the first booking and how many
bookings a person had beforehand now
this will obviously change over time so
we can do this to each date and it's for
everyone we know and also this
predicts risk of recidivism because
that's what we're training our model on
so we created our own baseline and it
actually did quite well so what you see
here is when you choose the percentage
of the population what is going to be
your precision that's the blue one and
what's gonna be your recall the red one
so obviously you want really high
precision and and what we see it's
really difficult because the line is not
really 200 people and we want to give
200 people a month but 200 is actually
like in the zero so we try to dry nicer
but in total it's 47% so that's quite
good just for like two features and so
we created our own model we tried to
train a lot of models as you can see we
use different model types for each model
type we use every possible set of hyper
parameters from the sets written here
there's a lot of them as you can see but
in total we used and the model types of
extra tree classifier random forest
classifier a decision tree classifier
and logistic regression and again a lot
of hyper parameters and then we will ask
ourselves how do we choose the best
model so I know this is really awful to
look at but what are we seeing here so
on the y-axis we're seeing the precision
each line and again I know you can't
really see line so trust me each line is
a type of model with specific hyper
parameters from the previous slide so
for example one line can be a decision
tree with a specific number of trees and
all the other hyper parameters and then
the x-axis is over time let let's say we
trained it in May 2013 in May 2014 2015
and 2016 so we're on our model not only
to be the most precise but we want it to
be the most precise over time because if
it's really noisy then that's not good
enough for us it's not gonna actually be
useful for our client because they're
not gonna trust the model over time out
of all of this the best was a random
forest classifier with the highlighted
hyper
parameters honestly they kind of mean
nothing but it is a random forest
classifier and this is how it looks
compared to the baseline as you can see
we do a lot better we actually do about
70% precision for the 200 people picked
to be out reached by the mental-health
facilities and even those that we get
wrong meaning that they don't really
have jail time within the next year have
a jail time within the next two years so
we're not that far off and so we were
kind of pleased with this but this is
not it we contribute to asking ourselves
how do we make sure that we don't do
harm when we try to do good and this is
why we looked into bias and fairness so
we wanted our model to be fair in terms
of gender race and age because if it the
soundhole misbehaves then we're actually
doing harm to the county right we use
the EM this is an open-source package
it's called Akitas m and you're welcome
to use it but you're also welcome to
contribute to it we've contributed
during our time there and I highly
suggest using it and it also has a web
app if you want like I don't know why
would you not want the Python API but if
you want so our first question is what
is the number of reentry's to jail
according to race and what we see is
that it's actually quite similar between
african-americans and whites the orange
one is people who return to jail the
blue ones is the ones who don't return
to jail in the next year so you can see
that obviously there's more white people
in general but also more of them go back
to jail and it seems somewhat similar
and then we ask ourselves and this is
gonna be like you're gonna answer the
questions so I'm not gonna answer for
you we ask ourselves what is the
measurement we want to look at so the
first question is do you want to be fair
based on this separate representation or
based on the separate errors on your
system so do we want to represent the
same number
or this of whites and blacks or do we
want to be wrong on the same percentage
what do you say
come on thank you so we're based on airs
Thank You Noah so then we ask yourselves
is our intervention punitive or
assistive in our case our intervention
is mental health so as someone said here
assistant thank you and then we asked
are we intervening on a very small
percentage of the population I recall
the image from later very small yes and
so we're gonna look at false emission
rates which is calculated this way it's
the false negatives divided divided by
the false negatives plus the true
negatives we don't want to miss people
because of what group they are part of
ok this is what it actually means and so
this is the entire schema if you want it
it's also available in the Akitas
website just like I thought it'd be easy
to see so we always have false emission
rates by groups and the head one is by
race second one is by sex and the last
one is by age does anything seem
suspicious the age yes so race and sex
we generally are fine but age we're
missing a lot of people who are under 25
compared to the people above 55 where
we're hardly missing any of them any
idea as to why yes exactly perfect so
yeah we didn't know that we don't have
data for under 18 we thought what we had
a table that said juvenile arrests and
we just used it and we assume that we
have all the data no we don't we don't
we didn't really have their IDs it was
like a mix of IDs and they didn't fit to
their adult IDs and so we were missing a
lot of this data which means that when
we gave this tool to our partners we
told them listen you got to fix that one
you've got to make sure that you're
using the same IDs for both and you got
to make sure because you have the
availability in
don't you gotta make sure that you're
okay on age but we gave them this tool
so once they trained a new model they're
gonna see this they're gonna see if
they're missing something if they're not
behaving somehow and then we also gave
him another tool because we felt like
that wasn't enough our tool the first
tool you saw was for each model on its
own but this tool allows them to choose
a model according to their own decision
so what you see on the y-axis is the
false amiss and emission rate disparity
given two different groups you divide
the false emission rate between the two
of them you want the value to be as
close to one as possible and then you
look at the evaluation metric in our
case it's precision so in general you
want to be on the y axis as close to one
as possible and on the x axis as much to
the right as possible again close to one
so here in this image you'll want the
orange ones that are on the top right
these three both have good false
emission rate disparities
they don't really differentiate between
female and male but also they have quite
good precision rates so this allows that
our clients to actually take a look and
understand for themselves what is their
decision and make a more informed
decision at that so they see this each
dot is a model they see it for males and
females but then they also see that
according to race and as you can see
according to race is a bit noisier and
now it's actually the same two oranges
and one orange but you can see that the
two oranges actually have a much better
false disparity at false emission rate
disparity than the one that was earlier
on top and then you'd probably want to
use those too so this gives them a
better understanding of which model they
should actually use so in summary what
we did is we converted a reactive system
of mental health outreach to a proactive
one we use machine learning for that
obviously we gave a club a closed system
for non CS clients and trust me this was
a hard task because explaining to them
what they see in the graph took me about
five hours and I am being really kind to
them
and in total we allowed user to account
for fairness and acquit ability by
themselves not taking the handles on it
to the model but rather telling them
look you need to be aware of this you
need to account for it you need to know
what goes on in the model so what's next
for the project the project is actually
now being implemented in Johnson County
there's a lot to test to see that mental
high reaches the right result do you see
that we're actually flagging the right
people and to see that we can actually
reach them because obviously calling
someone and telling them hey do you want
mental health assistance we believe you
need this because you're going back to
jail is not the right solution so all
this is currently going on by our
partners and with a team of data
scientists from youth Chicago and
they're moving this forward and this is
actually a project that's intended to
continue about more than a year from now
so hopefully it will yield really good
results and will become a beacon for
other governments within the US and
hopefully outside as well thank you now
all I had two questions
[Applause]